aquí nos dicen que la figura 2 es una
copia a escala de la figura 1 esta es la
figura 2 y esta es la figura 1 al
parecer la figura 2 no solamente ha sido
reducida a una versión más pequeña sino
que también fue rota da 180 grados o
dicho de otra forma está volteada y nos
piden que identifiquemos el lado en la
figura 2 que corresponda al lado
de la figura 1 aquí tenemos el lado
de la figura 12 en el vídeo y vean si
pueden identificar el lado al que
corresponde en la figura 2 ok vamos a
ver tal vez ya muchos de ustedes se
dieron cuenta intuitivamente del lado
que corresponde a ese lado
pero en este vídeo lo voy a explicar
metódicamente para que podamos ver todos
los lados y puntos correspondientes una
forma en que podemos pensarlo es que el
lado más largo en la figura 1 es el lado
veces
este es el lado más largo en la figura 1
mientras que el lado más largo en la
figura 2 es el lado h l así que el lado
b se corresponde al h el y basándonos en
ese lado más largo podemos observar que
ese lado tiene dos ángulos rectos
tenemos un ángulo recto en cada uno de
sus lados y después en donde se
encuentran esos ángulos rectos tenemos
el lado más corto conectado al lado más
largo en este caso el lado más corto es
de a y corresponde al lado l kan en esta
figura este es el lado más corto
conectado al lado más largo y forman un
ángulo recto si continuamos siguiendo
ese lado de la figura nos encontramos
con el lado a que en la figura 2
corresponde al lado
kj y eso contesta la pregunta el lado en
la figura 2 que corresponde al lado
de la figura 1 es el lado kj o lo
podemos escribir como el lado
y si alguien nos preguntara qué puntos
corresponden entre sí bueno podemos ver
que ve a corresponde a lk de c
corresponde a l h así que podemos saber
que por ejemplo este punto b corresponde
al punto l en la figura 2 y podemos usar
la misma lógica para los otros puntos
pero bueno ya contestamos la pregunta
aunque en realidad se trata de ver qué
lados o puntos tienen características
similares por ejemplo cuál es el lado
más largo en donde podemos ver ángulos
rectos y muchas veces nuestro cerebro
los identifica automáticamente si
rotamos esta figura hasta acá nos
daríamos cuenta rápidamente de que jk y
son lados correspondientes este es el
final del vídeo